hello freak [ __ ] yeah in today's
climate and environment I'm not
advocating cheating god I don't think
you should cheat I think we'll fun come
on fight that's a clue John I don't know
about all that
you want to know the craziest [ __ ]
rumor that I heard you John John Stein
please the crowd I can't tell you who
told me this this is the craziest one
the the stuff that he tested positive
for and what this doesn't make any sense
and people are saying that there's so
many months out the stuff that he take
tasted positive when he was tattooing
tested here and tested there the stuff
that he tested positive takes a long
time to get out of your system right
yeah that he was testing possible you
know where else that's stuff that you
find it you find it in creatine when
they get creatine sometimes from China
it is it's tainted with steroids they
use that creatine to cut cocaine so he's
doing the cookie there's one of the
things that they cut some cocaine with
is creatine cuz it looks like cocaine
God so he might get the bad batch if he
was partying monohydrate cocaine party
Johnny I wanna do a bump it's really
good stuff anyway I can't test positive
anyway it's just cool to be out of your
system ro bro I feel pretty swole to
little song comes on the radio dancing
it's freakin about all your birthday ten
days out before the UFC fight Oh what do
we do it's like the world wants them to
be a [ __ ] up a birthday you gots course
your new a couple bumps on your birthday
my birthday in a wheelchair John last
time you [ __ ] him up three weeks out
you did coke come on man bro you barely
trained um oh my god that's the case
just stop and think about it for a
moment if it was that stuff that's
best-case scenario Joe oh yeah and we
can tract and we can
he deals go your homes let me come in
and talk to you about where I get my
she's in Columbia homes you guys want to
go down there you're welcome stitches
down there know the taking in the
propeller plane broke across the border
we don't do that oh go do that in a bit
ski look how bad you want to catch this
guy Jordan well they don't want to
they're not in the business of drug
enforcement you don't want to catch that
guy at all and know the guy's not gonna
admit he's not gonna give you a baggie
this the plot of narc goes for oh it's
it's John just write narcos for it for
John John didn't tell me this so yeah
somebody told me this as a rumor which
sounds crazy but then read ban was the
one who called the dick pills last time
read ban said that if he's taking dick
pills like if the guy does coke he
tested positive for Coke and red band
was like if he does dick pills or if he
does coke he's probably doing dick pills
I was like what and so red BAM brought a
bunch of a man he's like you think
there's anything anyone knows what's in
these things it's true he's like they
have steroids and all because I've taken
cialis he goes and I've taken this stuff
it goes this stuff's way crazy that
really yes he says it's madness like a
wild animal and listen your dick is hard
as a rock best promo for dick pills ever
things like but they're gas station dick
pills that you're getting from some
[ __ ] third-world country if you're a
world-class athlete probably shouldn't
be doing that [ __ ] a bucket they used to
have pain in yes hundred percent
I mean I know 7000 yes do I be so
skilled to take that [ __ ] Brian won't
take him anymore and Brian takes
everything and he won't take rhino's
7,000 remember when they used to have
that life cereal commercial
Mike you won't eat he hates everything
Brian's the opposite of that let's go
let's see what the Rhino pills do my
least he did is right he did but my
skeptical hippo eyes there's because
again we're constantly looking for and
they're smart people around John so with
this stuff the others clomid in there
but clomid is a masking agent there's a
lot of masking wasn't Roman I thought
they found clomid in this show oh the
old one yeah he's a new one no new one
was what was it called
but some Russians your school
learn where the ball um yeah aníbal
taranta ball travel ain't that a [ __ ]
though if you're John you're doing a
couple of devil's dandruff and just
whatever it's your birthday that's the
case but they have found the clomid they
did find it in those dick pills I mean
it was in there there it is but also
make sense though wouldn't it like it's
a it does surgeon inhibitor 100% but but
it's also for something else it's also
for if you've been running you know deer
in it you take clomid to recurrent
things so it's in there like I said you
have a lot of smart people around you
where when the public cares dick pills
like oh it's not bad come on it's all
good baby you're gonna fight again right
so that now right if it's cocaine he
should be out we're not looking for
years
well you gotta prove that it's cocaine
first of all this is pure speculation on
my part gotta go get that cocaine was a
journalist if I was like working for
ESPN three source it would have already
had me pulled out of here oh you and I'd
be fine forget ESP one for our social
media too because why go my sources it
the one guy that is in the business
whose balls deep usually in this stuff
oh I don't give a [ __ ] I'm wrong night
which at the time I said like [ __ ] man
my source is saying my source is mmm
with three people but your guy that the
who knows who it is maybe it's the
cocaine dealer but no I should track him
if I'm John I'm hiring some private
investigator to track some [ __ ] down
it's too late though my god because he's
not I cannot tell you who my guy is but
he does not have a vested interest in
anybody being correct
he just has what I don't know what no no
no - he has what he has is a possibility
and he also was saying and even if it's
true good luck proven that now you're
screwed you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] because all the Commission
knows is trainable where the [ __ ] it is
I would like to find out from people who
actually know whether or not this is
possible creatine and cocaine yeah no no
not well that I've heard is true I don't
think I looked it up though I think I
heard it from other people I just
googled it in salt a bunch of places yes
I use creatine it's gross I see you're
doing
yeah that's what I have my masters in
broza
so see if see if it's proven that
creatine tests positive for that stuff
because that would be very very unique
to ran a ball examination in creatine
specifically creatine apparently and a
lot of the stuff that you get if you're
buying vitamins you're getting in bulk
and you're getting a mixed places and we
had issues the early on batches of alpha
brain that they didn't contain all the
stuff that it was supposed to and that
it was it had some stuff that we didn't
even put in there had traces of change
language you want to buy some right now
sure we can buy some it's a dollar one
two five US dollars per gram what's it
coming koulos Tabo acetate raw steroids
stir animal malaysia sourced or animal
creatine cycle timing
tam how much is the very first thing i
popped up how much is it five bucks so
much that they sell online that's
[ __ ] but i bet a lot of this stuff
is real steroids I agree what is this
bet veteran industry limited I think if
you've got some [ __ ] that's like sort of
legal I bet you could sell it you test
positive for it but you could probably
sell I've taken a lot of [ __ ]
supplements of my day and I never
flagged
I mean I've taken the GNC stuff that's
like extenders testosterone nothing ever
hmm and if you're John what the [ __ ] are
you doing see if is that was that say
that just showing you the supplement
itself thanks
see if you can find creatine
contaminated with Torana ball so you see
that what the baseball players get bus
if you just buy it that way yeah but
don't write Chinese creatine Taranto
ball just right creatine contaminated
with Toronto ball because apparently
more than one person has tested positive
in various sports from creatine specific
in baseball shitload yeah creatine works
I mean hell yeah it gives you a fat face
though made you swell up a little the
monohydrate doesn't that there's a three
of them the monohydrate like holds water
so yes we retain a shitload of water fat
yeah yeah get thick though get strong
real weight on this legit form but it
says there's 42 supplements that are
sold at GNC that can trigger a positive
test for animal and at this point this
was in 2014 you sadha had only found
seven of them but were any of them
creatine just seemed harder did did
anything come up when you googled
creatine contaminated with Travis that
was that was a form all that stuff so
one of any of those things are creating
CI totally makes sense man
I mean if you wanted to sell the
creatine that's the bomb yo my creatine
make you gain mad weight sign up on it
yeah for the regular dude just goes to
gym look good on tinder that's one hell
yeah I just want like a small son trying
to slam them DMS
[Applause]
[Music]